You're going to be learning
a lot about different rules for
performance in this course, but it's
important to keep a few things in mind.
First off, the tools that you'll be
learning are way more important than
the rules that you'll be learning.
Rules are helpful, but
they change over time.
It's much more important that you become
comfortable with the tools at your
disposal because they'll provide
the real insight into your app's
performance.
Along the same lines,
numbers change and bugs get fixed.
In fact, the numbers change part
even happened to us while we were
working on this course.
There's a quiz in the fifth lesson
where we ask about CSS selectors and
we mentioned that one of them is one
hundred times slower than the others.
The reason it was slower,
we found out, was a bug.
In fact, as we were working on this
course, the developers working on
Blink and WebKit actually fixed the bug,
and our comment was no longer true.
What this experience really
reinforced for me is that it is so
important to focus on the tools
not the rules, themselves.
Understanding the tools allows you to
measure first and measure often, and
measurements are the key to
understanding performance.
You should measure to understand what
performance issues you're actually
facing, and then later you should
keep measuring to decide whether or
not your changes
are actually fixing them.
So remember, focus on the tools,
not the rules.